THERE'S A REAL CLASH OF
CULTURES AND THERE IS A
DISCONNECT BETWEEN PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN THE BUBBLES --
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> OF NEW YORK, WASHINGTON AND
HOLLYWOOD VERSUS THE PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN THE LAND OF THE
BUBBAS.
>> Jon: UH-HUH.
>> WHICH IS THE LAND OF GOD,
GUNS, GRITS AND GRAVY.
THAT IS WHERE IT ALL COMES FROM.
>> Jon: I SEE. SO, SO --
>> IT'S NOT A BOOK OF RECIPES,
BY THE WAY.
>> Jon: IS THIS, IS THIS ONE
OF THOSE -- NO, I HOPE NOT,
BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T
SOUND TASTY.
>> AND THERE YOU GO.
IT WOULD SOUND TASTY IF YOU
LIVED THERE.
>> Jon: IS THIS THOUGH -- IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE IS AN IDEA,
THERE IS A SENSE OF LIKE, WELL,
PEOPLE WHO LIVE ON THE COAST
ARE NOT REAL, THAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT LIKE THE BUBBAS
ARE REAL AND WE'RE NOT.
>> NO, IT'S NOT, IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF REALITY.
IT'S A MATTER OF DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE.
I WILL GIVE AN EXAMPLE.
>> Jon: SURE.
>> THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO ARE WELL
EDUCATED AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
SMART.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY
WELL EDUCATED, LET'S SAY THE
HARVARD FACULTY --
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> BELIEVE THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE OUT IN THIS
PART OF THE WORLD WHERE I
LIVE IN FLY-OVER COUNTRY,
THOSE RED STATES THAT PEOPLE
THINK THOSE PEOPLE ARE NUTS.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> SO WHAT I WANT TO DO-- .
>> Jon: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
GOING TO SAY WHO BELIEVE IN
EVOLUTION, BUT THEN YOU WENT
A DIFFERENT WAY.
>> NO, BUT --
>> Jon: YEAH, YEAH.
>> WHO BELIEVE DIFFERENTLY
THAN THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THE BUBBLES.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> AND HERE'S THE POINT-- .
>> Jon: BUT YOU BELIEVE THAT
THE BUBBAS ARE BETTER THAN
THE BUBBLES.
>> NO, DIFFERENT.
>> Jon: NO, BETTER.
(LAUGHTER)
YOU BELIEVE THEY'RE BETTER.
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK --
>> Jon: YOU BELIEVE THEY'RE
BETTER.
YOU WROTE A BOOK CALLED "GOD,
GUN, GRITS AND GRAVY."
YOU BELIEVE THEY'RE BETTER.
>> BUT HERE'S THE POINT.
I WANT TO EXPLAIN WHO WE ARE
TO THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THE BUBBLES.
BECAUSE THOSE OF US WITHOUT
LIVE IN BUBBAVILLE WE GET THE
PEOPLE IN THE
BUBBLES BECAUSE ALL THE
TELEVISION SHOWS AND MOVIES
ARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN THE
BUBBLES.
>> Jon: YOU DON'T. NO, YOU DON'T
GET US.
>> SIX AND A HALF YEARS --
>> Jon: YOU DON'T GET US.
>> I HAVE COME TO NEW YORK AND I
HAVE SEEN THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE ATTITUDES AND LIFESTYLES
AND CULTURE.
IT'S NOT THAT ONE IS BETTER.
>> Jon: YES, IT IS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WELL, IF IT IS-- .
>> Jon: YOU BELIEVE ONE IS
BETTER.
>> IT WOULD BE
BUBBAVILLE.
>> Jon: HERE'S, HERE'S WHAT I
BELIEVE --
>> LET ME TAKE THAT POINT ABOUT
THE -
>> Jon: BUT THIS FEELS
LIKE IT'S A CONTRIVED -- THERE
IS NO REAL BUBBLEVILLE AND
BUBBAVILLE. THERE'S, THERE'S --
>> OH, I WOULD SAY-- AU
CONTRAIRE, TO QUOTE JOHN KERRY.
>> Jon: WOW, YOU REALLY HAVE
LIVED IN NEW YORK.
(LAUGHTER)